[موسيقى]
في البدايه بالرحب فنانه نجومنا استاذ
محمد فراج شوقي بالرحب بكم
207 الغرفه 207 بيتعرض على شاهد
مسلسل صعب انا شايفه انتاج الصعوبات
واجهتك وانا شايفه التصوير صعب الاجوال
[موسيقى]
نقطه صعوبه ممكن اتكلم فيها بدايه بالورق
اللي مكتوب علشان انت بتكتبي يعني قليل
قوي بالبلدي كده يعني علشان يبقى الكلام
شارح نفسه قليل جدا لما بتلاقي في الجمره
دي اللي هي سبينس
[موسيقى]
همم حاجات من هذا القبيل
قليل قوي لما بتلاقي ورق جايلي الجاهز
بنسبه 90 و95% كمان جاهز على التصوير
والحدوته متفصله ومشروحه باقناع مش طبيعي
انت بتقري حاجه مش منطقيه ومع ذلك مقتنعه
بها مليون جنيه
فدي اول حاجه كنت محتاج بس ابيها لصعوبه
الورق اللي كتب وتامر ابراهيم ببراعه يعني
فانا هنا علشان تحكي هذه المشاهد همم
وتمثليها وفلاش باكات وايهراس مختلفه
بتروحيها ازمنه مختلفه بتروحيها وترجعي
ثاني اصل الحدوته كل دي بتبقى همم
عقد عايزه تتفك وتتفسر بشكل كويس للمتفرج
علشان يفهمها بثلاثه والحمد لله رب
العالمين بفضل ربنا اولا واخيرا مجهود كل
الناس اللي اشتغلت في هذا المسلسل من اكبر
حد الاصغر
طلع بالشكل المشرف دوت وباعتبر نفسي محظوظ
علشان عملت حاجه زي ديت يعني
بالعكس هو في دراما كبيره قوي قوي وعلاقات
انسانيه وحب وكره وغضب وهمم يعني في مشاعر
انسانيه مختلفه جدا جدا اللي بيغلفها
الحدوته اللي احنا بنتكلم فيها
2007 وان شاء الله باذن الله في رمضان
اللي جاي باذن الله في مسلسل تاليف اخراج
احمد فوزي صالح اسمه بطن الحوت
جمال
[موسيقى]
الفنانين بلاقي مشاركات فنانين من كذا
دوله المنصات مع بعض في مسلسل شباب طالع
جديد افكار جديده قادره تقيمي جزاء وتشوفي
ده ازاي غير شكل نقدر نقول لسينما او الفن
العربي
هو انا حاسه شويه ان الموضوع رجع زي زمان
لما كان فيه ممثلين كثير قوي مثلا من
الوطن العربي من سوريا ولبنان وكده بيجوا
يشتغلوا في مصر كنا بنعتبرهم المصريين بس
حاسه كمان ان البلاتفور فتح لان في منصات
معينه امم بتتشاف الوفر الوطن العربي فلما
فطبيعي جدا ان علشان تتراكت كله جمهور
بيبقى من الجمهور ده بيحب الممثل بتاعه من
كل بلد فاا في ممثلين فاطمه
ناس كثير قوي مثلا من السعوديه يشتغلوا
همم في بروجكت ويعملوها وطبيعي لان انت
انا مثلا عشت شويه بره مصر بيبقى عندي
اصحاب من كل البلاد ف بالعكس انا شايفه ان
هي حاجه
الواحد في الحقيقه عنده اصحاب من كذا بلد
طبيعي جدا في الدراما مش لازم يبقى بس
الموضوع قائم على بلد انا حاسه ان هي
فتحت الشباب اكشن احنا محظوظين ثقيل لان
المنصات دي ابتدات تشتغل دلوقتي
وعندي مسلسل ثاني برده مع علي ربيع اسمه
نص ثاني في رمضان